thailand 2020
a salute borrowed from movie hunger
games and symbolizes protesters
three demands hong kong
2019 protesters asking for the
government's response to their five
demands
[Music]
from the use of helmets umbrellas secret
chat groups
to the way activists distribute
resources the two pro-democracy protests
share
striking similarities and
activists from the two places do feel
connected in some ways
as tens of thousands in thailand defied
a ban on gatherings
and turned out to protest activists in
hong kong
voiced their support
hong kong people stand with thailand
just like how
people in thailand stand with hong kong
in 2019
thai people in thai is also a place that
really inspires hong kong
a lot to continue our fight for freedom
more freedom and democracy a goal that
both protest movements share
both are also contending with political
repression
in hong kong it's the chinese communist
party tightening its grip on the
semi-autonomous city
in thailand its combined power of the
military and the monarchy
the bond between protesters is further
strengthened by the so-called
milk tea alliance which also includes
taiwan
the online coalition got its name
because the drink is popular in all
three places
we have the milk tea alliance between
hong kong taiwan
and thailand in which we all long for
democracy
so we want everybody here to support
hong kong as well
because hong kongers are facing violence
not much different than us
[Music]
rallying in solidarity protesters in
thailand are lighting up hope for
themselves
as well as their counterparts more than
a thousand kilometers away
joining us is hangshan lee who filed
this story hangshun tell us more about
the milk tea
alliance sure it refers to a loose
largely
online coalition of activists from
thailand hong kong and taiwan
and it's got the name milk tea because
it's a drink very popular in asia
and all three places have got their own
variation of that drink
all of them very tasty of course but
it's not just the tea
so all three places have very similar
political struggles
and activists in the places for um in
the case of thailand
and hong kong they have been
there had been some protests and the
protests have been
anti-authoritarian and all the activists
share the same goal they want
to have more democracy i love milk tea
too but it is a very strange
name how did this start it all started
earlier this year when a thai actor
retweeted a post
that referred to hong kong as a country
and then his girlfriend a taiwanese
girlfriend
also tweeted something about the
coronavirus that angered
chinese netizens so online users from
china or both
started to troll and flooded social
media platforms with pro-beijing posts
so to fight back some thai netizens
started to use
some memes very quick witted memes
with hashtags and one of them was mukti
alliance
and that quickly got a lot of echoes and
instantly
people from hong kong and taiwan had
been joining this movement
and posting uh created even more mims
and so it all started as a joke but then
it became a real bond among the
activists i mean how tangible
is this alliance so things are happening
on social media but to what extent
are protesters in hong kong and thailand
supporting each other
as we've seen in the report thai
protesters have been demonstrating for
hong kong at their very own protests
and in the meanwhile hong kong activists
have also
tried to help their counterparts um
over the weekend there had been an
online petition
at change.org that was initiated by thai
protesters
and the website has been instantly
blocked by the thai government
because it's sensitive and so after
reading the news hong kong
activists have campaigned online and
asked fellow hong kongers to help sign
the petition for
thailand and also signs uh like
stand with thailand refugees can be seen
in hong kong as well that's very
interesting to what extent
is there going to be an impact when we
look at these transnational protest
movements
i think it already has an impact so
through the multi alliance
there's been quite a lot of exchanges
among
thai and hong kong activists
and thai protests um in fact
thai protesters have uh adopted a lot of
strategies
uh from hong kong from the hong kong
protest last year that's why
when we compare the pictures of the two
protests we've seen that the pictures
are so similar that's the reason behind
it
and also i think a new tactic of protest
swapping
has emerged and it's unprecedented
because
it's two completely different places um
trying to promote each other's course
and that's now all possible um
because it's all online now and i think
this kind of borderless resistance
can really change the protest culture in
the coming years
that's very interesting and of course
you also see oregon protesters looking
online to see how hong kong protesters
have been fighting back against police
very interesting the globalization of
the protest
hangshan lee thank you
you